carlos santana is a global music icon
yes
[Music]
the guitarist and his band first topped
the charts with evil ways off their
self-titled debut LP in 1969 the song is
still one of his most popular today 50
years ago this weekend
Santana took the stage at Woodstock in
Bethel New York at the time he was an
unknown musician well that didn't last
long he went over the massive crowd with
his guitar riffs and his band's
percussion this year he's celebrating
that historic performance and the
twentieth anniversary of his Grammy
award-winning album supernatural which
includes the popular song Maria Maria
Carlos Santana is with us Carlos welcome
thank you so much for being here a lot
of big anniversaries for you as we said
when you took the stage in Woodstock 50
years ago you were 22 you didn't even
have an album out yet it just came out a
week before right so but everything
changed really didn't it with that
performance fortunately yes but you've
admitted you were actually hallucinating
in that performance I'm still that day
you were really illusionator taking a
little what what did you take in it was
my friend Jerry Garcia you know we went
back and forth yeah because we used to
do would be called therapeutic kind of
taking like an inner bath in a shower in
peeling layers of illusions you know
humans pick up all kinds of like
personas that it's not really you and if
you don't be careful this persona can
throw you into a mystery mystery [ __ ]
yeah so it's permeate always important
to be a person rather than a persona yes
but see you were taken and you thought
it would wear off by the time you went
on but they called you up early yeah so
you get on stage and you're a little
tipsy and you look out at the crowd and
you see and you think what I think just
what I thought is what my mom taught me
immediately hold on to God and Trust
trusted God which makes who makes
everything all right already
we'll guide you through all this energy
because we're talking about energy yeah
what stock is about energy all these
people is about energy
and the more important in the masculine
or Jerry Garcia or Whistler with the
music as how these people were able to
coexist with unity and harmony like we
humans did it in the year 2000 that's
what that's what we're still talking
about Woodstock because humans aren't
quite capable to do the opposite of the
shootings and hurtful things that would
you say you wouldn't even mind having a
Woodstock every other weekend or
everyone because why tried that it
didn't work yeah it could work we need
to convince mayor's across America to to
allow Saturdays and Sundays from 10:00
to 10:00 to have like what we just have
Lovings yeah people have tie-dyes
barbecues Kanye's music and and you have
grandparents grandchildren all
celebrating life without the fear we
promote way too much fear in every
channel and and so we're becoming
creatures of like you know creatures of
being paranoid but I believe in
transmogrify your fear with the joy that
you are inside from that performance 50
years of music you have a very
distinctive sound you don't have to be a
crazy got a guitar fan to know Carlos
Santana song you recognize it how did
you develop that sound thank you for
asking that you know I think it was my
brother Tony Bennett who said if you
take from one person it's called
stealing if you take from many it's
called research like a sponge I take
from Billie Holiday and or this rush in
my name is Nicole train I take from
everybody because I trusted by the time
I my fingers in my heart presented to
people it's gonna sound like me anyway
it's been said that you sing with your
guitar you've got new music out that
Rick Rubin the uber super iconic classic
producer says that your latest music
here you go Africa speaks is gateway to
people's consciousness what is this
music mean to you your latest music mean
to you thank you for asking that
mystical medicine music to heal a
twisted crooked world infected with fear
the ingredients in the nutrients from
African music which is my first
fascination
you know it's joy it's joy
African music makes you cry and laugh
and you if you have cried in your job
it's the kid it's okay if you cry tears
of gratitude yeah tears of joy yeah yeah
you don't have to be embarrassed about
that it's okay you know for a man or a
woman to to shed tears of gratitude or
joy all right we'll call us st. Anna
thanks so much we'll be right back
here's a check of your local weather
gratitude always